reject yeah good morning my name is rana
jaramillo and I'm developer and Omega
and I will spend the next 30 minutes
trying to convince you that you should
get your hands dirty and start playing
with hardware I believe that disruptive
technologies change society and we can
drive the change in different directions
for instance the web can be a really
nice place in a great place but it's not
only the technology behind it but it's
the culture that would manage to build
around it especially if it's is a
culture the value openness transparency
collaboration diversity and creativity
mmm and we are now moving into the
future where applications will be
connected and driven by sensors rather
than by user input and computing will be
everywhere and on everything and we need
to start thinking about what kind of
values we want in this new space and why
I'm talking to you well this is a Venn
diagram by brand initial and as you can
see there is a large set of people who
knows you have a script it small set of
people who know C C++ and a large set of
people with awesome ideas and we need
more awesome you know about software and
you know about networks but we all need
to learn more about hardware not
necessarily because you will be building
products but we need to know enough in
order to dream about the possibilities
and think about what kind of future we
want my talk would go like this first a
bit about my background then why I think
now is the right time to start tinkering
a question about hardwood and you have a
script
where you should start and at the end
fallax here we'll do a bit of walking
and i'll do some show-and-tell i was
born in 73 the same here these three
characters first were introduced
probably a lot of you don't know who
they are or what they are but during my
childhood they fuel my life on
fascination for technology and robots
and still to this day they shake my tree
may interest in exoskeletons and
prosthetics and androids in all that
sort of stuff my early teens my biggest
wish was a hero one robot kit and it
probably cost it an arm and a leg
because my parents got me a dremel
instead and they told me that I could be
my build my own and this started a life
of tinkering and working with mechanical
contractions and much the same way I
wanted a Terry game console and my
parents they bought me an atari st
computer and that got me into coding and
we'll really got me hook was the first
time i was able to control pixels on the
screen and even though i was into tech
and software I didn't went to
engineering school writing passes and
optimizing sorting algorithm wasn't my
idea of fun so I went to art school and
did architecture and industrial and
graphic design but still in high school
I keep coding and doing small projects
and got a part-time job with multimedia
development and in this agency the web
exploded and suddenly I became a 1 pixel
gift table ninja
and we were churning out small web apps
even though this agency had serious
software developers but they were busy
doing custom desktop applications for
enterprise they didn't want to have
anything with the web five years laters
all this sort of custom development was
done on top of a lamp stack as web
applications and the developers that
didn't embrace the web they were gone a
show of hands out of curiosity how many
of you has another background but
software engineering okay nice the in 94
Paul Milgram described in a paper this
space we now call the Milgram continuum
at this is a place were this is a mix of
the virtual environment and one side and
the real environment on the other side
and technology is quickly filling this
space up and the thing is that each
major technology converging in this
space right now hardware software and
connectivity has previously had a huge
impact on its own so there is no limit
to the amount of how you're currently
seeing based on the spected implications
of this development for some of this
technology media and industry has coined
this label IOT or Internet of Things and
probably you already can't find the term
in a [ __ ] bingo card and why I think
that you can get a foothold in this
space well there is a trend where
hardware is undergoing a democratization
process and this process is driven by
different forces but I will highlight
three open hardware component ization
and rapid prototyping
let me ask again how many of you have
heard about Audrina's epidermal chippers
good well adrenals are the best thing
coming out of Italy since life's pizza
it was born as a platform for
prototyping Amy primarily at designers
with no background background in
electronics or programming and their
decision to release the blue brains with
a Creative Commons license change the
industry that on to that point was sort
of clothes and very proprietary today
there are thousands of platforms
available for physical computing that
takes the messy details of
microcontroller programming and wrap it
up in a easy-to-use package one project
and very excited about is the tehsil two
coming in november and they they managed
to pack and node.js in the on the board
and they have to sniff the architecture
of clock and play where each component
has a corresponding npn package so let
me ask how many of you have actually
played with an arduino oh that's nice so
I'm preaching for the claw I can see
well the first time I I got to turn an
LED on and off with an Arduino it with a
very special feeling it was sort of the
same feeling I that that got me into
programming for the first time and the
things that code for ascending from bias
to the physical realm is a very powerful
experience and the next aspect i will
talk about its component ization which
i'm not really sure it's a proper would
but picture what the NPM is doing for
the know Jason ecosystem but then thing
translated to hardware if your project
need a GPS positioning or take pictures
or biometrics on
or any kind of sensing or communication
like Bluetooth or Wi-Fi well there is
probably a component for that and these
components they take care of things you
don't need to think about internals or
the circuitry you just add it to your
project pluck it and import libraries
and you're good to go and their
companies companies like Adafruit and
sparkfun and pollute I have you covered
they have a lot of amazing stuff and
also tutorials it used to be like it
when you need a component you have to
read a spec sheet and out of that find
out how things work but today you really
have a lot of help adafruit they
themselves say jokingly that they are
not a hardware company they are a
tutorial company with a gift shop the
third aspect I will talk about is rapid
prototyping 3d printers and laser
cutters and CNC machines they are
becoming much more accessible today you
can get desktop models of all these
machines and they're within the reach of
individuals and the number of fab labs
and maker spaces around the world keep
greeting at the same time the software
to manage this machine is becoming it's
constantly improving and cat system used
to be really expensive and now they're
becoming a commodity the latest
generation of this software is
cloud-based and collaboration and
versioning is at the core of these
packages so how is this relevant yep I
could persone personally I can tell you
that the first iteration of fellig's
looked like that it was a one-off made
in my shop and made of aluminium it you
need tooling and precision and it's easy
it's difficult to update
and it's difficult to share simplifying
the default the design and going
digitally I can create much much cleaner
hardware which is easy to reproduce easy
to update and easy to share so what's
powerful about these machines and
software and software systems is that
they allow you to share physical designs
the same way that we share code so
what's about with JavaScript and
hardware the embedded system used to be
programmed with low-level languages and
they still do mostly but thanks to some
badass developers we have alternative in
JavaScript and Johnny 5 is a JavaScript
programming framework that allows you to
control a rich variety of hardware and
but to be honest the first time I heard
about your script and hardware I was
like hmm but I after playing with it I
actually found out that this is not a
case of what as we can from do in
javascript you don't need to clutter
your code with pooling you can add an
event least attack an event listener and
wait for the call this is because and
and the thing that hard work being a
band base and a synchronous by nature
make it a really good March then we have
the prototypes which provide a required
flexibility to create some very neat
abstraction layers to hide some of the
underlying complexity of all this
hardware and Johnny 5 takes great
advantage of all these I can illustrate
with an example there are a number of
components you can use to measure
distance and
all of these components they have their
own way of speaking with the
microprocessor they can be sound base
light base or lasers and JavaScript
johnny-five wrap it up in a proximity
class and it can looks like and it looks
like this in phallic see I have a sharp
sensor this is a infrared sensor and the
code to manage it is quite simple you
get Johnny Five and you instantiate a
board when the board is ready you
instantiate your component and you tell
the component if the distance to you
make sure change please tell me and say
I got the present for christmas i got a
light a light laser component the only
thing i have to change is the name of
the controller that's that's quite
powerful and so in the same way that
jquery sort of abstract the document
object model Johnny Five is taking care
of all this underlying hardware for you
yeah well well you well you can't get
started you can get some toys I will
recommend that you get a star kid there
are a lot of start kids that came come
with an assortment of sensors and
actuators and then you get 25 and start
playing with the examples besides the
community Johnny Five has really good
thing going for it is the documentation
and for each example you get this nice
diagram showing how you you can wire
everything up and then get this book is
a it's not only about robotics a
there are some neat projects wearable
projects and also IOT project they would
sort of learn you gives you some best
practices and ideas of what you can do
what's possible in this space but don't
lock you need to lock yourself in a room
and hide away and start tinkering you
can join the community you can join a
node BOTS event there are events and
meters around the world if there is no
meet up close to where you live you can
consider starting your own chapter you
can join a fab lab or make a space how
many here are members of makerspace or
fab lab that's not much well really
consider it you will meet people doing
stuff with the hands it's really
inspiring and probably you be the only
one around who really understand
programming and you will be treated like
a wizard so I'm into robotics I like
four legged robots the current state of
the art is represented by person
dynamics they have spot which is a
electric four-legged robot and big dark
which you probably have seen that a
hydraulic engine power gas power beast
they can run they can jump that's a
mighty cheetahs and they can take a
beating but there is a still a long way
to go that's Daisy and I've been working
on a four-legged robot for some time
it's called Felix and my goal was to
create a simple and cheap lake robot the
kids out there tend to be a complex and
use a lot of servers
and actually I think that kind of creepy
and my goal was to create a robot with
eight servers and the challenge
challenge there was to explore the types
of gates that were as possible with only
eight degrees of freedom the system
space um in adrenal you know I have a
server control chip some sensors on the
adrenal we have free matter which live
as firmware and the fermata talks to
join a 5-over socket our air all over
the serial port on top I'm using spray
CS and socket i/o to provide the UI so
when you have to learn to get a
four-legged robot walking you need where
there are three steps or you need 3 a 3
parts of your code one part will be
dealing with the position of of your
feet because you don't want to deal with
the rotation angles you just want to
decide where you place the foot and then
calculate the angles using trigonometry
and then you want to do some motion
planning like how is your step going to
work you have a track you have a lift
and then you combine these motions into
gates mmm now will do fellas will do a
bit of walking and
I think he's better can you see him is
cease on the floor is possible team
and you can see this sensors they map
the distance and tell him not to bump
into anything there's a lot of light
here so he's quite confused as you can
see but let's see if he managed to do
some walking speak enough again the UI
is talking is talking to the Arduino
using socket i/o and this is a creeping
gate I can tell him to walk forward stop
sort of go backward you didn't want to
go backward you're a bit not no I didn't
want it you know well he still has to go
forward he can turn around the thing is
that because he doesn't have the right
number of a mobility in the car sir he
is constrained so when he when he wants
to turn what he does is that he take
small step steps with the lake at that
side he wants to turn to and he can sit
and he can day and he has also another
gate which is the trot which is sort of
a weird tapping dance let me so
and this is the little brother it's
using a smaller servos with not much
torque and the idea is to develop this
into kids that you can play with with
children or all the people at least in
the hackerspace kids really like to play
with this stuff because you can use the
sensors to for instance he stops when
there are obstacles in front and
actually I haven't learned him that he
shouldn't go there so I go back to my
talk see there are some links to all the
resources available check out the Tesla
I would recommend it take out Johnny 5
to get you started and go on play thank
you
reject